[Music]
hi I'm Ted baliker with Reason TV and
today I'll be speaking with Olga
gardener Galvin Galvan is an author and
founder of ENC Press so Olga tell me a
bit about ENC press emc press is a very
small alternative press
we don't want investors we don't want
anybody's money you don't want money
only the readers money we've been
offered some investment opportunities
and I don't want to take anybody's money
because I don't want absolutely anybody
but making decisions and what sort of
books do you publish I have some
literary stuff I have some pure humor
stuff but mostly I'm interested in
social satire and it's from is it fair
to say broadly speaking the libertarian
perspective broadly speaking I would say
all my satire has one thing in common it
all kicks up screams against any kind of
nanny state interference and so what are
some of the titles we have a book called
junk by Christopher large on who is an
anti-drug law activist and he took a lot
of research that he's done in his
capacity as an activist he took
documentation he's he took some evidence
of government excesses in the war on
drugs all justified by war on drugs and
here he plays drugs for for the sake of
the novel with sweets and junk food it's
a society where candy is banned candy
you read me salt we're getting there
yeah we are getting there he was joking
a few years ago but since the book was
published in 2005 it became more and
more like it and of course the first
thing that happens is there is a huge
black market for junk food because the
demand does not go away and of course
there are jobs created to to combat the
junk the junk food and of course there's
the government bureaus and czars and the
whole war on junk food and people get
killed over candy you in addition to
having the this point of view in a lot
of the books you also have interesting
opinions on big publishing
in general well the ways of big
publishing would necessitate small
alternative presses because there are
fewer and fewer big publishers and they
have to pasteurize and equalize
everything to market to the broadest
possible audience because the economics
a big business and it's all in a
left-right spectrum it's like you know
well I want politics in fiction that's
that's a big no-no in big publishing in
fiction right it's extremely polarized
it's practically country from this side
take back your country from yes it's
practically possible to publish any kind
of middle-of-the-road
let's hear out both sides book by a
major publisher do you see that changing
it all over no actually it only getting
worse but now I mean we have for
instance increasing disenchantment with
the the Republicans and Democrats people
tend to like Republicans only because
they're not Democrats and growing
numbers of Independence or people
identifying as independents do you think
maybe that's a you know glimmer of hope
maybe it's a glimmer of hope but these
increasing numbers of independents are
not being offered let's say the same
entertainment opportunities as the
extreme right and left wings there's
plenty of books to preach to both choirs
on both extremes and there's very little
books movies TV shows you name it in the
middle that would appeal and entertain
this huge growing numbers of
independents so they can't really come
together there's something keeping the
independents scattered and preventing
them from having any kind of group
discourse except maybe South Park we can
all agree on South Park we could all
agree on South Park but that's just one
thing hmm and a lot of us can also agree
on The Daily Show and that's another
thing and even that even that we all
know
all right he's just really really trying
hard to be fair and balanced in the best
sense of the word it's interesting that
you would choose this career path where
you investigate the nanny state
oppressive governments coming from
growing up in post Stalinist Soviet
Union talk about what the atmosphere of
that was like just growing up not having
access to the sorts of books and
materials that that you're selling these
days I grew up in a society where
everything was decided for you and
making decisions like which books to
read was dangerous you could get
arrested for for reading a book imported
from the West out in point of view if
somebody saw you but this is something
that you still did correct yeah we'll
talk about that so in Stalin's times
people had no idea what was going on up
out there in the 70s we started getting
some information trickling and people
stopped people started traveling a
little bit what books were you reading
my parents and their friends would get
ahold of books forbidden in the Soviet
Union but published in the West and and
usually smuggled in from the West and
passed around and sometimes the family
would get only one evening to borrow
this book and read it and give it back
and sometimes maybe three days there was
a luxury and that was Solzhenitsyn that
was you know if you have a lot of them
were writing satire
well not soulja nielsen of course the
guy didn't have an ounce of sense of
humor but he was still being I mean he
was exposing the regime and in a in a
way that was very dangerous oh yeah I
read the day in the life I read a lot of
gulag when I was fifteen that that shook
up my whole world that changed my
perception of everything and I think
that's when my parents started thinking
that you know maybe it's kind of
dangerous to keep me around in Moscow
maybe we gotta go
you